les villes qui vont se démarquer puis
qu'ils vont réussir l'avenir civile qui
vont s'attirer davantage de talents de
haute qualité
jacques ménard qui a longtemps dirigé la
banque de montréal au québec est décédé
hier à l'âge de 74 ans très engagé en
éducation en santé dans le développement
de l'économie de montréal philanthrope
également jacques ménard n'était pas un
homme d'affaires comme les autres il a
été l'instigateur de je vois montréal
fait montréal et il y a quelques années
il a été vice-président du groupe
d'experts sur la littératie financière
en 2010 engagée aussi dans la
persévérance scolaire la fondation du
chu sainte justine
l'organisme fusion jeunesse il a signé
le manifeste pour un québec lucide a été
président des expos de montréal
administrateur président de la chambre
de commerce du montréal métropolitain
l'ancien ministre des finances raymond
bachand l'a bien connu on le joint via
facetime au mexique ce soir bonsoir
monsieur d'achat bonsoir vous
connaissiez vous connaissez jacques
ménard depuis longtemps de vivre être 50
ans vous avez travaillé avec lui c'était
un ami pour vous c'est un ami très
proche famille excuses et demande ma
dévotion mais on s'est connus et je
regardais j'accepte un est assez
exceptionnel que c'est un click id dans
tous les domaines de la société on
perdra de sa carrière d'affaires qui est
la principale mais hommage aussi à la
banque de montréal qui le laissait la
liberté d'agir dans tous les domaines il
ya cinquante ans est connu dans le
communautaire entre autres parce qu'on a
avec marc johnson yvon deschamps fond d
oxfam québec
ils sont allés à toronto pour obtenir la
souveraineté d'oxfam québec et qui
devenus autonomes et affiliés
internationalement mais après ça vous le
dis ce centre est dir coprésidé la
campagne de sainte-justine beaucoup
alors qu'elles symphonique de montréal
avec un tag à noël sont mal
communautaire quand je t'ai mini ses
finances et j'ai décidé d'y financier
robert lepage pour des diamants ces gens
qui a pris la coprésidence la campagne
de financement pour qu'elle cherchait de
l'argent du public
alors ce côté là l'intéressé bien sûr
comme vous le dites le contenir et côté
d'éducation 1 publié un livre sur la
santé publique
un livre sur l'éducation qui l'écrit
lui-même l'éducation pourquoi c'était
important pour lui de s'engager comme ça
de parler publiquement en faveur de la
santé de l'éducation de la littératie
financière pourquoi c'est important pour
lui de faire ça socialement parce que
jacky des valeurs citoyennes au fond ce
qui ont été éduqués peut-être dans
l'autre siècle on dira dans les années
20 aux années 60 avait un grand sens de
la communauté de l'importance de la
participation citoyenne et de
s'impliquer a pas juste de faire sa vie
faire de l'argent comme ben qui il a été
exceptionnel dans sa carrière on peut en
parler un peu de sa carrière a commencé
chez gbl sur un aspect de bourges mais
toute sa carrière professionnelle est
devenu le leader de montréal au québec
l'association canadienne des valeurs
mobilières c'est un homme de valeurs
mobilières moi je t'ai reconnu aussi
quand j'étais président je suis me
trouvais chez view c'est lui qui nous
accompagne pour transformer métro en
compagnie publique
la compagnie à ce moment là dans nos
grands des acquisitions mais il est
toujours voulu participer à la société
par faire de la politique active ça
c'était comme une règle de chagny
pourquoi pas de politiques partisans
quand vous êtes impliqué 80 heures par
semaine dans tout je pense qu'il y avait
une entente avec marie-josée c'est très
sage je dois dire de ne pas s'engager
dans la vie politique oui là il m'a dit
ma compagne et moi quand j'étais quand
j'étais candidat mais de pas lui même
être candidat mais de participer de
toutes sortes d'autres façons on y avait
demandé de présider le conseil des
drogués mais qui est pas un conseil de
chasse il dit n'a fait jusqu'à tout
récemment il était président du conseil
de montréal international qu'il a
abandonnées parce que montréal lui
tenait à coeur vous l'avez suivi ni il a
fait beaucoup pour montréal
balma il vous est appuyé lorsque vous
vous êtes présenté pour être chef du
parti libéral du québec est avec vous il
appuie quelques semaines encore
dominique anglade
oui tout à fait de sa chambre d'hôpital
on a organisé cette petite fille nation
parce qu'il aimait beaucoup et dominique
qu'il a connue très impliquée du côté
sportif aussi un vous avez évoqué mais
il était du premier sauvetage des expos
monté le groupe financier il en a
présidé le conseil
le fonds de solidarité est un partenaire
il était du deuxième sauvetage des expos
quand l'autre assure décideront des on
avait monté le groupe
on voulait 75 millions l'avait déjà
accumulé 70 millions d'investisseurs
québécois et jefferies le rien est
arrivé et on connaît le reste le pouvoir
absolu qui donnait 1 commandité mais
parfois on se trompe sur le caractère
des êtres humains et on s'est fait avoir
voilà mes canadienne montreal aussi
exactement ce qu'il a il a été banquier
de jill est pour vendre les canadiens la
famille molson et tu t'es fait il était
très préoccupé et moi j'étais ministre
parce qu'il savait que dans les montages
financiers probablement qui auraient
besoin d'une quote part soit de la sgf
et d'investissement québec j'ai résidé à
frapper ou deux portes les juifs de trop
conservatrices et demain notre
investissement on ne pouvait pas prendre
parti alors y avait à la fin une quatre
finalistes lui son rôle c'est de
maximiser unis étaient un peu inquiets
parce que le groupe de chicago était
très intense mais heureusement toute fin
la famille de manson d aqua fille il
était loin devant tous les québécois
loin loin de battre conté mais quoi
intéresser au mieux ses propriétés
québécoises mais jay laprete un très bon
propriétaire
je vous écoute monsieur bachand et
canton quand je vous entends et quand on
lit sur jacques ménard c'est des
décennies et des décennies d'histoire
économique d'engagement dans le monde
des affaires la santé l'éducation
montréal son oeuvre est dans son
héritage et danse vous vous allez
retenir quoi de l'héritage de jacques
ménard un monde où chacun semble acquis
et quelqu'un
eux qui ne disait jamais non qu'ils
acceptaient toujours d'aider que ce soit
les grandes organisations
que ce soit comme coach ou parent pour
des jeunes à faire parler de fusion
jeunesse au cours des dernières années
est très préoccupé par l'évolution de la
société et d'aider les gens à vivre un
passionné de montréal du québec et aussi
du canada ouais c'est rare que quelqu'un
qui a les plus gros oeuvre et du canada
et du québec au plus haut niveau
lorsqu'anna d'en être convaincu par ce
que c'est c'est quelqu'un qui nous a
tous accompagnés d'un arbre et tous les
domaines qui touchent notre vie au cours
des décennies qui est ce monsieur
bachand merci pour cet hommage ce soir à
jacques ménard
merci beaucoup à perdre si j'arrête